it's the beginning of February 2017 so
it's time for another monthly update
video I'm going to talk about what went
on during the month of January and what
we have coming up for February 2017 I
always like to begin by talking about
three big things and the first of those
big things is a lecture on Plato
Athenian democracy and Greek
enlightenment this is the kickoff of our
second year of a quarterly series so
I'll talk more about that in the
February section the second big thing is
something that will be coming out later
this month and that is a set of courses
in our teachable Academy on Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics people have been
asking for them where when are they
coming out where are they I'll talk more
about that in a bit and the third big
thing is partly about January and partly
about February and partly about you know
going into the rest of the year and that
is that I'd like to tell you about the
MKE and that is Milwaukee stoic
fellowship which we got started here in
January and we've got another meeting in
February so a lot coming up and a lot to
talk about from the month before let's
talk about the month of January 2017 I
did get a lot done but nowhere near as
much as I had originally intended and a
good bit of that he had to do with the
effects of some long you know lingering
and recurring illnesses you know colds
flus that sort of stuff that that took
quite a toll there there were quite a
few days where I would do some things
then be totally worn out after after
doing them nevertheless we did have a
few interesting events we started the
year off with a new set of lectures and
discussions in the philosophy in the
philosophy and speculative fiction
series starting with Philip Jose farmers
a world we had a great discussion early
in the month and then we held our
half-hour hagel session using our new
interface for that have some great
discussions with that and we had the
very first MKE that's milwaukee
MKE stands for that MKE stoic fellowship
meeting ten people showed up for that
some great discussions we decided what
we were going to be focusing on we
talked a lot about you know prospects
for you know events and what would be
coming up during the year so there was a
lot of great discussion and some some
planning as well two other things that
that I think are kind of cool one of my
videos was actually used in part for an
NPR program to the best of our knowledge
this one was on the notion that hell is
other people so of course they they took
something from one of my lectures on
sart's play no exit and that you know it
went out to about 200 channels
nationwide so that that's pretty cool I
had people writing me and saying hey I
heard you on the radio
towards the end of the month I also
engaged in another conversation
this one about an hour and a half long
about sart's play the Flies with with
the guys on the noetic platform that's
that's a new sort of podcasting and and
resources platform and they asked me if
I wanted to talk about the flies with
them and so I said sure that sounds
great so that that's a lot of fun I did
a lot of tutoring over the month of
January I'm now at the point where I
have not only a lot of sort of ad-hoc
hey doctor say Lori needs help with this
right now but some some regularly
scheduled people who are working on a
curriculum with me and that's that's
very enjoyable I also did some
philosophical counseling and some
coaching a lot of hands-on work using
philosophical resources I very much
enjoy
that and the month has been spent doing
a lot of curriculum designing and
adaptation of things that I've developed
in one platform bringing them into
another platform to try to make them
accessible I did also get quite a bit
more blog writing done something that
I've been setting myself as a goal to
get more popular oriented writing out
there there's the entire stoicism today
things I didn't actually write anything
in stoicism today except for writing
content for the pages for the site but
there's a lot of overseeing the articles
that are coming out and soliciting new
articles and giving feedback and a lot
of work for that I am doing some writing
that will appear in stoicism today later
on down the line but I did some
publishing in Iraq cestia no @tk which
is my main blog some stuff in half hour
Hegel and for the first time a peace of
mind came out in the partially examined
life blog which I was particularly happy
about that one is on Epictetus and
what's in our control and what's not in
our control I've also been working but I
haven't gotten it yet to the point that
I'm happy with that short book providing
stoic dog motto or sayings or judgments
opinions is another way to translate it
dealing with the emotion of anger that's
sort of a preparatory work to the the
larger book that I'm working on down the
line and as far as video work goes I did
some things that people have been asking
for for a while dr. Sadler won't you do
more of those personally oriented videos
so I did quite a few discussing some of
my philosophical commitments and
interests and stages that I have gone
through I'll put the links to those
below I also started doing some more of
those frequently asked questions or
frequently brought up issues things that
I can when people put a comment and I
think oh that's perfect for it I can put
it in
and they're kind of nice because they
don't just say hey here's what you said
here's my immediate response you know do
a little bit of reflection and leading
the person through hey you wrote a
comment of that sort maybe here's
something that you want to think about I
also did another video which has gotten
quite a few views I started doing I'd
done one before our philosophy and
current events and when I watched
Trump's inaugural speech I felt that it
would be a good idea for me to create a
video commentary on it it turned out to
be about an hour long going through some
of the key themes and talking about you
know some of the implications bit of the
rhetoric and structure that was going on
there in addition to all of that I kept
on releasing the Aristotle core concept
videos which go into the Aristotle
classes and finished up with those
that's that's quite nice to finally be
done with and I got my six half-hour
Hegel videos done for the month very
nice that I've got the support that I do
for my patreon supporters so that is
what happened during January so what do
we have coming up in the month of
February well quite a bit of stuff we're
beginning with events with a talk here
locally in the Milwaukee area on the 7th
6 p.m. on Plato Athenian democracy and
the Greek enlightenment that is at the
Frank Weinberg library and that is the
first of the second year of quarterly
talks we did talks last year on a number
of philosophers in this philosophers in
the midst of history lecture series
those are always really well attended
and a lot of great discussion so I'm
expecting this will be a lot of fun on
the 9th a little bit further out from
here in Brookfield we at at 7:00 p.m. we
have the sec
of the the philosophy and speculative
fiction series this one is on something
that's a little bit different I you know
I've been using this series to talk
about writers that that I particularly
liked when I had a lot more time to read
science fiction and fantasy and horror
and things like that and go back to them
and talk about philosophical themes and
I picked Madeleine L'Engle without quite
remembering that she's not really
considered at least her time quintet
which is what we're talking about here
it's not really considered to be you
know adult fiction it's all found a
young adult and children's section
I remember the books as being quite good
and as I've been rereading them I've
been you know quite impressed as well so
that's coming up on the 15th at 5:00
p.m. Central Time it's important to
remember the time zone for this because
it's an online event we have our public
half-hour Haegele Q&A and discussion
hour so if you're interested in talking
about Hagel you want to show up for that
we use free conference call comm as our
way of you know getting everybody into
the video conferencing and sharing
materials and anything like that and
ending the month on the 23rd at 6:00
p.m. at the Shorewood Public Library we
have the MKE stoic fellowship the second
meeting where we will be discussing
epictetus is enchiridion chapters one
through five and all the different
themes involved in that and cool ideas
like you know what is in our control and
what's not in our control what do I
desire and aversion mean and what is all
this
stoic stuff right so that is going to be
a lot of fun as well so if you're in the
area come on down to the events if
you're not at least for the lectures you
will be able to see videos of those
being posted fairly fairly regularly you
know usually within a week what else
have we got coming up well I'm being
interviewed for several different things
and I don't know
what's going to come out at what time
over the course of this month as a
matter of fact I had one interview
earlier today but you know there's often
a long turnaround time so we'll see just
when they come out and I'll announce
that sort of stuff probably in my social
media a lot of tutoring appointments
already set up but there are slots still
available so if you're interested in
that that sort of thing you can go to
the link below and check out our
tutorials for reason I own philosophical
counseling I've got some some regularly
scheduled appointments and I've got some
new people interested in engaging in
that with me so that's great as well I
particularly enjoy that I'll be doing
some coaching in addition to that and a
good bit of curriculum design this month
as well that's that's one of the areas
that I I work in taking philosophical
resources in some cases adapting them to
corporate contexts or it's a leadership
you know discussions or to personal
development in some cases just teaching
straight-out philosophy although usually
we end up discussing those sorts of
things along the way so I've got a lot
of that work going on as well as a
little bit of consulting on particular
projects and I'm going to be doing quite
a bit of writing over the course of this
month I'm gonna get that stoic dog mata
anger book at least the manuscript
finished I don't know whether we're
going to you know get all the self
publishing things required for getting
that out there in the world done by the
end of the month but we'll certainly
have a manuscript done by the end of the
month and hopefully I could get it out
there and make it available for people I
am going to be doing quite a bit of
writing in our exes do you know I take a
half hour Hegel if I've got the time
heavy metal philosopher I'd love to get
some stuff going in that
stoicism today of course a lot of behind
the scenes work that I'm doing with that
and I probably am going to try to sneak
in one of my own pieces in
there if I can if not that'll be there
in March
partially examine life I'm working on a
piece for that blog and you'll also see
something of mine coming out in policy
of truth my colleague earphones blog
which is really quite quite an excellent
blog for discussing political matters
and geopolitics and timely stuff so
there's all of that popular writing I'm
also working out a few academic pieces
as well you know I'm trying to get some
of these articles that I've got
basically almost done or needing to be
polished or needing to be updated in
certain ways trying to get those out and
ready to send to journals for
publication and I'm also trying to work
on some book chapter stuff as well but
we'll see how much that I get done video
work I've got a good bit of video work
that I'm going to be doing I'll do some
more of the personal videos people
responded very well to those and there's
plenty of other portions of my life that
I haven't talked about yet that I
certainly can do I'll probably be doing
at least one more philosophy and current
events and it probably will have to do
with our current political developments
as they're happening got some half-hour
Haegele videos to shoot we're now in the
third section of the reason portion of
the work so we're getting close to the
end of that and I'm gonna do some some
videos in that existentialism series
that I haven't gotten to for a long time
I'm definitely gonna do something on
sart's play the Flies and if I have the
time I'll do some additional stuff as
well I'm not sure which author I'm
leaning to quite quite at this time but
I will be doing something else and if
you've liked the the half-hour Haegele
videos or if you liked in my other
channel the Epictetus and karidian close
reading video
where I'm going through it line by line
I'm going to be doing something similar
to that in that other channel as well on
another text another short text a short
text that often gets assigned to
students and if you're like me when you
were a student you read through and
you're like what in the hell is this and
that is Aristotle's categories it's
often assigned as an introduction
Aristotle and succeeds in turning
students off from Aristotle but it's
actually a great text and I will be
working through it providing a lot of
examples and and a lot of useful
information particularly about
terminology you know line by line by
line and hopefully I'll get all of those
done this this month so I'll be I'll be
working on that I the last thing I want
to mention is the Aristotle Nick and
McKeon ethics courses in the reason IO
teachable Academy I'd mentioned that you
know there was quite a bit of illness in
our household this this last month and
so that set you know me behind a little
bit I'd hope to have these out and ready
for enrollment fairly you know fairly
early in January that didn't didn't pan
out but I'm hoping that by mid-february
we'll have these classes there and ready
to enroll so if you've ever wanted to
study the Nicomachean ethics in depth
and detail I'm going to be you know
providing that as as a at your own pace
set of to online courses one on books
one through five the other one on books
six through ten seems like a reasonable
amount of material for each course and
I'm really looking forward to seeing
students you know learning about
Aristotle because I
he's really one of my favorite thinkers
so that is what we have coming up in
this month of February I hope it's a
great month for all of you and I will
see you at the events or in some of the
online places where you can find me and
so just you know keep on reading and
thinking about philosophy and figuring
out how
can apply to your life and have a great
month